greetings I am Brainiac an Android and
collector of knowledge and
civilizations but collecting cities has
lost its fulfillment I now want to
collect
words Lego Batman 3 sees us going into
space for the first time brainia ex's
turned up he's found green Lan he's
found the power of the Green Lantern's
ring and with the Green Lantern and all
the other lanterns he's basically going
to make the shrink rate and he's going
to collect Earth we've got to stop him I
wasn't planning on giving
up we thought Lego Batman 2 introduced
DC let's now go to town with it let's
really go into these characters to bring
this world to life we really wanted to
dig into the The Wider world of
everything that was not only DC but also
Lego were creating so from a DC
perspective we try and get as much
access to anything we can so with comic
books TV series the films cartoon
anything we can get our hands on with
Lego Batman 2 the setting was still
Gotham and we had around about 50
playable characters now we're Beyond
Gotham there's way more stuff to play
with this is almost an A to Z of DC
Comics we've got every single character
we can possibly get into this video game
we've got some incredible playable
characters uh like blue be Shazam is
amazing the lanterns Sinestro laugh Le
atrus St Walker Star Sapphire and we've
also bought some incredible new villains
and bosses have read comics with polka
do man he's in there you might have seen
a Crazy Character like condiment King
he's in there with his ketchup gun and
his mustard gun mix as pitlick is in the
game Mr
mix Mr uh Mr Mixel I I can't pronounce
it it's one of those tricky ones it's
pronounced Mixie as pitlick there is so
many characters that we've just found
and then actually fallen in love with we
had done amazing opportunity expanding
uh to The Wider DC Universe to go crazy
with with creatures with different
worlds with different abilities has just
opened up a world of possibilities for
us and what's great with this is these
characters allow us to do things we
wouldn't have done in the past we have
the return of big figs in the game but
not only do we have big figs we now have
flying big figs the great thing about
Lego games is that we're allowed to play
with dynamics that that haven't been
experienced before and and as such you
can put characters in situations where
things that happen between the Justice
League members but to be able to bounce
characters like Grundy off of Wonder
Woman when they're working together it
really allows us as a team to kind of
bring the humor out Wonder Woman gruny
help
lard we're always looking for ways of
giving the fans a character they know
and love but also giving them something
new and fun Batman and to do that across
over 150 characters and know that the
fans are going to love this is a is a
real Joy so Lego Batman 3 Beyond Gotham
is it's about us being Fanboys and and
delivering a game that Fanboys are going
to want yes we've got the Justice League
yes we've got the Legion of Doom yes
we've got the lanon characters but we
wanted to be the biggest the best Lego
Batman game there's
been
for